let me pull up this next story here so
i've got some good news let's let's talk
about where we're heading cnn plus to
cease on thursday two days earlier than
announced cnn plus couldn't even fail on
schedule right oh that's wonderful that
is brutal well this is this is a big
change i mean cnn put uh 300 million i
believe into it right yes 300 yeah
million and you know the the story
behind it is uh you know somebody i know
at discovery called it uh
an ego project basically a zucker ego
project and it was tossed in
by the guy who left there kind of as a
we wanted this we're going to do it
you're stuck with it and i don't think
anyone thought that they were just going
to shut it down because you know
that's a pretty big move to bring over
chris wallace and so forth now wow i had
reported that when chris got over there
he was you know having people count
like interns count how many times he was
furious because you know the staff was
different it wasn't as big of an
operation his ego
one of the little secrets is like most
of these anchors hate each other like
there's very few people like don lemon
and cuomo used to have these little chit
chats boy when cuomo left lemon couldn't
talk about him bad as fast as he could
and you know like famously wallace and
tapper
hate each other
the problem was when zucker left he left
this giant vacuum of power because he
was hands on
and you know the thought that and my old
boss dan abrams did a thing once right
when this launch was like who thought
this would be a good idea
like who thought you wanted to watch and
tucker like somebody said to me and i
was kind of invested but not super was
like you know that tapper has a book
show on this i'm like a book show we're
going to listen to him talk about books
on streaming
and i remember thinking to myself that
can't be true
and there it was and you know
i've been in the media 15 years and
there's this not only is there a city
bubble in new york and dc there's also a
media bubble within them that they think
that they live in this moment and they
live in these big
important roles and you if you try to
question their judgment or or disrupt
their judgment on how things should work
and you know you know it's kind of like
when facebook years ago said pivot to
video and all these companies spent
millions of dollars spending on video
equipment then nothing happened because
i guess millennials wanted 15 second
videos not 30 second videos but this was
you know we need a streaming service
because the kids are watching streaming
and most people think to themselves
there had to be like a lot of focus
groups and stuff yeah they paid money to
be told that this would work
when if you asked a person on the corner
would this homeless person who had a
bearer in like had watched cable in the
last five years would say god no he
wouldn't you know he'd you know but they
did
did they not do
they did a study
and i can't remember whether it was kpmg
and i don't want to but it was one of
the big ones that said this will be x
amount of x whatever now
to be fair when when zucker came on
when he took over he introduced
documentaries now you look at cnn today
and you think wow they have some pretty
good documentaries
and people made fun of him when he did
that so he's had some good ideas
let's just say that if they had endless
amounts of money and endless amounts of
time
maybe once no one had cable anymore and
this was the only way to watch cnn it
might have worked but when discovery
comes in and has you know x amount of
billions of dollars in debt and this
thing is costing and you know
wallace is making seven million i mean
that's what they they're paying him oh
yeah absolutely had to be about worth
everything seven to ten million dollars
because
that's about what lemon and those people
make now the odds are that waltz is
probably going to end up with cuomo's
old time slot at nine right because you
got this guy what are you gonna do with
them he's a good brand the problem with
him when i reported this he has no beach
head both sides hate him equally like
the left had him because he was near fox
the fox people hit him because he
couldn't just be quiet and leave he he
had to you know poop on tucker and
and the left and they don't you know
they remember this and so he's kind of
this island of people who but but i
heard that the new the new leadership
wants to purge cnn political stuff so
it's happening if you've just if you're
a casual watcher and watch say brian
stelter who right now is kind of this
thing to watch as far as the tempo there
he's the guy who used to every sunday go
after fox or tweet at fox or say this
stuff about he hasn't said anything
about fox because they kind of set the
rules where this isn't about this is a
news organization this isn't about going
after another news organization this is
about
you know and then the ukraine the
ukraine stuff happened perfect timing
for the people in discovery who wanted
to see cnn go back to news because they
do an excellent drive callister ward and
all these people or bombs going after
them it reminds the only people who are
watching cable boomers
of you know bernie in iraq when you know
we for the first time saw war happen
live during shock and awe so it kind of
reinforced that there is a business
there now the problem with that is no
one's watching cable news anymore and
unless it's a crazy moment happening
people aren't running to the tvs and god
only know you guys in your 20s aren't
sitting there watching cable on your pa
if you even have a cable tv package it
used to be that when i heard i i saw
that sound yeah when i saw a tweet and
it said thing happened i would turn on c
correct i don't do that anymore right
fox and they like but but also that
whole breaking news thing used to be
when there was breaking news now fox
says it every commercial and you it's
kind of lost its luster where you used
to hear that noise and something big was
happening
but this will be probably one of the
largest media disasters for i hope for
hundreds of years from now i mean it's
the epic size of this you can't even
begin to
there's there's part of me that likes
would like to believe that the people at
cnn putting the project together saw the
market research that showed it wouldn't
work they're like hold on let's just
send it to snopes first let's see if
they can let's see if they can debunk
this research telling us it's not going
to work again you can't imagine the egos
at play
and you you know they live in now hudson
yards this gigantic building on this
island with looking down at people and
they all talk to each other they all go
to the same places they all you know are
all above everyone else and you know the
lack of failure and they just can't
figure out why physics works but this
cnn plus is the perfect example of the
information cnn presents itself correct
they live in a bubble where they're all
farting and then rushing over to smell
the person's fight and telling everybody
it smells like it's i call it naval
gazing and it's if you go to these
parties you'll see like i'll tell you
one thing working at meteorite the best
thing that ever happened was the cnn
launch parties when they launched this
thing i don't know what the number is
but it was hundreds of thousands of
dollars for the launch party of this
giant logo
giant logo but no it's just all of the
media people come from all the different
media places that's why you know fox is
the out loud outlier but you'll all see
them with each other at different
parties and it's all this little club
they're in and they all know each other
and they've all worked with each other
that's why you see media reporters that
you know will always you know kind of
hedge what they're going to say because
they're thinking well who knows what
they're going to own someday and i might
want to work for them
wouldn't it be hysterical if you turn on
cnn they're like cnn plus is doing great
yeah i know it's awesome well they did
the best network ever
are you kidding me
matt dornick
he's a conservative gay guy
who
was kind of invented for trump because
the cnn pr used to be the kindest
sweetest people
like if they working on the other end of
it when they didn't like something it
would be this nice email and they got
matt
to just become this bulldog that was
basically the trump version of a pr
person at cnn but anyway he famously
said it was doing great and they were
hoping and then it went out of business
like two days later seeing them plus
yeah so matt dornick this is a funny
story here it was pointed out that joe
biden is not a practicing catholic
because by definition he is and he
doesn't give
to catholic teaching and so someone
reached out to cnn
explaining this cnn you called joe biden
a practicing catholic he is not that is
a factual error you should correct it
matt dornick screenshots the email and
tweets it out saying this is really
gross which personally personally
speaking i don't think it's a great
communication strategy it's like
screenshots someone's email and then you
post it calling it gross but also he
comple he dismissed a blatant like
clear-cut fact yeah he's he's kind of
the representation of what happened to
cnn at in the trump era in that it was
all
they felt the only way to respond to him
has become what see they viewed him as
just this ignorant loud buffoon and what
they ended up becoming was the ignorant
loud buffoon like
i'm i the chris wallace news makes me
feel really good like
what's what's the word schadenfreude
yeah yeah no and
he was fine until
you know he left people like megan kelly
when she left she went to nbc now i love
megyn kelly and
but everyone knew you know you are what
fox be makes you your audience isn't
going to go to nbc in the morning that
was weird but she ended up with 30
million extra bucks in the bank because
they because she she said something
offensive about again she was black
santa and then said something she was it
wasn't even offensive no but it was like
why is that offensive and they're like
you don't know but they think they just
wanted an example no no no everyone
knows it was everyone knew it was a
pylon she knew it was a pile on that's
why she got paid and off she went and
now she did didn't they they initially
did was it the first the morning show
with megan yeah well she had the morning
show since she's like dancing yeah she
then she said this
thing uh she asked why was blackface
offensive why was blackface offensive
it's you're a new she should be in jail
no but you're a newspaper she belongs in
prison so you know that's the point like
what's the question you can't ask
anymore is how the news is made not what
should like there's no more like chris
wallace's father mike wallace
you'd be scared out of your wits when he
walked in the doors because there was
nothing there was you know no agenda
with him now of course they were all
left-leaning but still you know
we've come in
we are in a period where it's the words
you're not allowed to say you know it's
the words there's a there's a m like why
do gay people get a month like if i'm a
reporter and i went into the
headquarters of gay incorporated
why did you get a month like what
happened why does everyone have to
change their logos and except for in the
middle east and why are you okay with
that yeah and why you know and you can't
show you know dr strange's new movie and
then in there because it's a gay
character does that bother you nope you
can't it's like where did lgbtq plus a z
where did that come from well you can't
ask those questions correct well but i i
will say i thought it was strange that
they moved megan kelly from what was it
fox news primetime yeah to nbc morning
shows like a family woman-oriented thing
and it's it's what happens to media
people it's they you know and i love her
to death i love them all but they you
know you lose your mind you become so
famous that you think it's all about
that yes that's what cnn plus is but
let's let's let's talk about some other
uh good news some other some other good
news here well you're pulling this up
can i just mention something to his
earlier point so you said that cnn was
kind of trying to do this tough guy
thing and mimic trump and i i noticed a
little bit of that and i think it's
funny because a they clearly
misunderstood it's not just that people
like that trump was a tough guy they
liked who he was going after but even in
the example i brought up of of matt
dornick going this is really gross
that's not a tough guy thing to say no
that's not can you imagine trump going
this is really gross quite frankly no he
would actually go after the person right
they didn't know how to do it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the tim cast irl podcast but if you
want to check out the full show live
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
and if you want more special access
content head over to timcast.com and
become a member your membership helps
sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there is a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8pm and we'll see you all
there